hello everyone Perry here with another
Collider Sundance interview for you
brought to you by Kia Telluride a huge
thank you to them because that means we
get to talk movies with you guys and I'm
thrilled about it I'm thrilled about it
right now because we have the director
and the ensemble of Paradise Hills here
first of all welcome to our interview
suite we are thrilled to have you I am
gonna leave the synopsis in anybody's
hands who would like to take it because
this is a movie that I have seen it but
I don't want to describe too much
because there were so many surprises
that I was not expecting well thank you
so much I am so happy that it's playing
so well in the festival I just watched
it yesterday for the first time with an
audience of some 500 people at the
library and I'm just so happy that you
know that it's its audience which is you
know young women and I made this film
for my you know fourteen-year-old self
are liking it and they are gonna have a
blast with these characters and the
story I'm curious for the ensemble here
how the script read the first time
because based on what I saw on screen I
imagined this script must have been like
hundreds of pages long just to describe
the costumes and the visuals in the
setting well the script came and it was
a normal length script but it came with
a beautiful lookbook kind of a vision
board of what everything was gonna look
like because I mean there's no real way
to describe what's analysis brain you
kind of have to have a visual because
it's it's you're right I mean when I saw
this lookbook I was blown away because
it was just kind of kind of a there was
something nostalgic about it but
something new about it and I don't know
it just completely fell in love with it
the colors the uniqueness of the sets
and she just had everything mapped out
so I thought why not kind of go to
Barcelona where we shot the movie and
experiment with this amazing creator and
this amazing cast so what is it like on
set for a movie like this because there
were certain moments where I'm assuming
there had to be digital components so
you can continue to
build the set but how much was there
practically for you guys to work with I
mean you'd be thinking that a lot of it
is CGI it and it's not not when it comes
to set which what just goes to show the
architecture that you have in Barcelona
because truly when everything you saw
like the stairs at Mila's sitting the
stairs that were going up and down the
fountains at the set the buildings
because that quite people thought I had
a couple of people asking me oh the
building how did they CG I was like no
that's an actual real house of someone
and that was that was incredible for us
because everything was there when it
came to art and let besides you guys
could talk more about the gross garden
when it came to the end of the film but
most of it is just there so it was
exciting it was thrilling we could not
believe that we were able to be shooting
in something so beautiful and at the
same time narrating such a bleak story
because it is truly like sort of
wouldn't Emma said nostalgic and obscure
and there's a kind of confusing
component to it consistently without
giving away what the film is about but
the the sets were I mean sometimes
people thought the water was like CGI'd
and we're like no we were actually on a
cliff and that was the ocean yeah I mean
even I was like this doesn't look real
and it Israel is being on a set like
that kind of intoxicating because as the
movie goes on and you know it right from
the beginning that there's something
sinister happening there but just being
there and being enveloped in that and
also wearing this incredible wardrobe -
are you guys kind of swept up in at all
oh yeah it was like we were in another
world I mean because we were in a
different country I didn't I don't speak
Spanish
it was like a whole lot of language and
then you walk onto these sets and I was
like we're in a different worlds like
old together
it was really incredible and then the
outfits you're in it's nothing like
reality so it makes it really easy to
kind of fall into these characters and
really get in that mindset which was
really cool you brought up the Rose
Garden and I really do want to ask you
about it but I also don't want to spoil
anything so can you tease a little bit
about the villainous nature of your
character or maybe not even villainous
but I would call it like more
manipulative um well I mean she's
definitely a bit nefarious if you ask me
but um you know I listen this this woman
it's it's it's hard because she's got
these amazing strong girls and she's
literally just trying to take everything
special about them and destroy it in a
sense emotionally and mentally and the
way that Alice was able to portray that
not just through script but also through
the buildings that we were in and also
in the caves you know that juxtaposition
between the super brutal modern
architecture but then this very organic
cave with the roses and and you know how
these roses really kind of are you know
an analogy for these beautiful girls and
and it's it's wonderful how how the
script visually you know it really
describes like emotions which is
beautiful part of the reason why I took
back the word villainous is because I
love the conversation about playing you
know maybe a traditional villain and a
movie but also the requirements of you
being able to understand where she's
coming from because essentially even
though what she's doing is terrible she
is kind of doing her job yeah well she's
definitely doing her job and because I
told her afterwards I was like it's so
crazy to me that I read the script and
then I see Mila and a part of me is like
I liked her so much and that takes a
really talented actress to bring that
and like it's really important to you
like her the whole well you definitely
sympathize with her you know listen the
fact is it's coming from her own
insecurity and pain and that's where all
of this you know just evil stems from is
actually someone who also went through
having a parent that put them down and
you know it's like the cycle of abuse is
constantly continuing you know she just
takes it to another level much more
glamorous level
I agree that's so beautifully explained
and also I think that the real villain
in this film is female competition so
she's kind of subject to her character
is kind of subject to a standard that
she kind of control and that has a
company of her her entire life and to
sort of cope with that pain I feel like
she extends that extender to all of the
girls in the residence and sort of makes
her are leaving out the sig litteraly
girls were just a little easier to think
it's an important and worthwhile
conversation to have with I personally
for myself our viewers out there could
really have a positive influence on
someone just to discuss something about
yourselves that maybe you didn't feel
super confident about or you didn't like
and then came to the realization that no
that's what makes me me so is there
anything along those lines that you guys
can share I think it was really
beautiful last night Nora brought it up
because Nora who's not Aquafina who's
like the quirky is the most fun girl she
used like we've had heart-to-heart
conversations or like over and
securities and she was like this thing
that I always thought it was like I
wouldn't fit in is what made her such a
successful like persona and it is hard
you know I think that at the end of the
day the beauty about this film and I
think that what made us as actresses
every single one of us is we grew up
watching all these films where we were
fed this idea of cool and uncool
loser versus cool popular versus loser
like consistently over the like our
trajectory of growing up and I think
that it's beautiful that for us as young
women to put that out there for new
generations of like this film is
completely the opposite this film is
about feeling comfortable about yourself
having your insecurities we all go
through them I mean I can't tell you the
amount of times that people will say
certain things about you and you look at
yourself in the mirror and I I don't see
it I you see your flaws and even as a
public person you feel flawed 24/7 its
we're all the same
everybody does everyone we live in such
a world now we're like you know with
with instagrams social media in all
forms it's like you're fed this image of
like you
someone's in a bikini every day of the
year in beautiful weather and looks
amazing and it's it gets exhausting I
mean I have a sister who's 17 years old
and I see her struggling so much with
just like feeling comfortable and who
she is like her own skin and and it
makes me really sad and so to do a movie
where you're saying like these are girls
that are all so different but all feel
good about themselves and I mean God
forbid a young woman feels good about
herself
like obviously I mean really and then
it's like if someone feels good about
themselves oh my god they're obsessed
with themselves it's like no they just
feel good about themselves and we should
it's never good enough so it's important
to put today yeah I think yeah and I
mean I'll go sometimes where I think
it's it's healthy to not be looking in
the mirror a lot sometimes like when I'm
working I tried it like avoid looking in
the mirror and just like think of myself
how I feel not like how I see myself I
think it's important to like always get
back into your body and just like you
know like do you feel good then you look
good like correct move on that was try
for it beautifully said yes that was one
of the ways appealing things about the
character to me is like in the first
line pretty much with uma we meet and
it's like my parents sent me here to
change and I'm happy with who I am and
so I'm just gonna treat it like a
holiday and that was really cool because
I was like oh sweet we've got someone
that's just like confident now you hear
that in films nobody right I never got
to I need a change and it's like no you
can be confident in who you are as you
are and for other women it's huge and
we're so lucky to be partnering up in
the 90s I have I understand well I'm
thinking about like 90s teen comedies
and it's like oh you take your glasses
off and you're fine I still love she's
all that but I don't I don't need to see
that again
another real bright spot in this movie
is the sisterhood too because you do
need to find that center in yourself
personally but you also need to surround
yourself by those people that will kind
of help bolster those ideas and make you
feel confident as well so can you guys
talk a little bit about just forming
that kind of family as an ensemble
because that is
something that really radiates off the
screen here yeah we're the Sisterhood of
the Traveling Pants I wish I fit in we
know it's so cool I mean to to get to
dive into a movie like this that we kind
of you know we had an idea of what it
was going to be but you know we're kind
of going into it a little bit blind
flying taking two planes to get to
Barcelona to be somewhere where I don't
speak the language I'd never been and
get to like meet a great supportive cast
of girls where we were all just you know
get having big dinners and laughing and
walking around and exploring the city
and it was a really it was great that we
shot this movie on location because if
we had shot it where we all lived I
don't think we would have become as
close and you know we had nice or we'd
be in each other's hotel rooms literally
like laying on the bed just talking for
hours and hours anyway I'm happy to hear
big dinners were involved because all I
can picture right now our tiny little
cups of milk and mini meals no that was
just to like put my two cents in coming
into this cuz I wasn't on the entire
shoot with you girls and when you come
into production that's already started
there's always you know you're nervous
because you don't know how people are
gonna treat you and what to expect and
you know I've I've been so rare in my
career that I've been welcomed with such
open arms by a whole cast of people no
but you know it's it's it's a testament
to how open and connected you guys allow
yourselves to be as women that there
wasn't that competition off set that all
the girls were supporting each other and
then supporting me on top of that you
know it's not all actresses that are
like that they're good people you know
but it's true it's we all took care of
each other genuine caring that I mean
really after this conversation now my
heart is full I feel like I need to do
that after I walked out of the farewell
the other day the first thing I did was
call my grandmother and now I
I want to call my friends back in New
York thank you guys so much for being
here today
huge congratulations on the movie guys
Paradise Hills keep an eye out for it
like and share this video to thank you
Kia Telluride for making these
interviews happen we will see you soon
with more Sundance coverage
you